- [Narrator] While
dinosaurs roamed the Earth
and pterosaurs ruled the sky,
sea monsters called ichthyosaurs
dominated the world's oceans.
Ichthyosaurs were ancient
reptilian predators.
They first appeared
about 251 million years ago
during the Triassic Period.
20 million years before
dinosaurs came about.
True to their name,
which means fish lizards in Greek,
the earliest ichthyosaurs
looked much like lizards with fins.
Over the course of their
100 million year existence,
their bodies transformed
and became more akin to fish in shape.
They had long narrow skulls
and jaws that were lined with sharp teeth.
These teeth were used to catch prey
like fish and squid.
Their eyes were the largest
ever recorded of any animal
which helped them see
through the dark waters of the deep ocean.
In fact one species had eyes
that were over 10 inches wide.
Their bodies ranged in size.
Some barely reached
the length of two feet.
While the longest specimen
was about 85 feet long.
They had paddle like fins
and a vertical tail
which help ichthyosaurs,
despite their great size,
zip through water at speeds
of over 22 miles per hour.
All together these qualities
put ichthyosaurs at the top
of the marine food chain.
By the late Cretaceous Period,
about 25 million years
before an asteroid
wiped out the dinosaurs,
ichthyosaurs became extinct.
Some scientist believe
it may have been due
to severe climate change.
But the exact reason why
these early sea monsters died out
is still a mystery.